this is brutally honest advice for men
to win in their 20s I made my first
million at 26 I crossed 100 million net
worth at age 31 and this is my road map
for things that I learned along the way
I'd like to normalize a 6 day week 12-h
hour per day work week for men between
16 and 28 and despite all the selfworth
voodoo that social media and Society
will tell you you are valued based on
your utility and when you're young you
have none but you have a lot of energy
and so trade that energy for experience
points and become useful the first rule
of Entrepreneurship according to Alex is
use what you've got and the reason I
like that is because many people always
don't start things because they don't
have the capital they don't have the
connections they don't have the whatever
insert insecurity or projection of blame
and power they want to put on but the
first rule is you use what you have and
so it's about resourcefulness not
resources and so if you have energy you
use the resource you have you use what
you've got to trade to develop
experience to develop proof that you can
get good at a skill and you only get
good at a skill by not being good at a
skill and repeating it and then failing
at each time and then making incremental
improvements which take many many
repetitions until you actually get good
and this may be a little controversial
but I'm not here to be nice to you I'm
trying to be kind which might mean that
it hurts a little bit so let's make this
practical if you have less than $100,000
in savings and you would like to to have
$100,000 or more in savings these are
the things that I would recommend doing
and that means that you have to check
out your ego it's your ego is gone for
this all right you don't care what other
people think because they're not going
to be there in 10 years all right
because you have a whole new group of
friends that are way [__] better and
cooler so one stop eating out discount
groceries only that's if you're super
poor if here's my caveat if you know how
to make money you already have a base
level of skills then eating Chipotle and
whatever whatever you can door Dash it
in so that you can keep working the
moment I realize I can make $500 every
30 minutes by selling I was like oh I'm
never buying I'm never cooking food or
grocery shopping ever again anything
that was less than $500 an hour was was
now immediately outsourced all right but
this advice is for people who are super
broke okay so if you don't have the
skill set yet at all and you're
struggling to just get things going then
you need to be completely on the
defensive so that you can have enough
money so that you can start taking bets
cuz the only way that you're going to
get ahead is that you have to make bets
you got to make bets on education you
got to make bets on opportunities you
got to make bets on inventory you got to
make make bets on software you want to
start a Shopify score you want to start
a school Community you want to start
something it's still going to cost some
money right you might have to buy a
camera you have to buy some software
that helps you edit videos like there's
some expenses all right and so having a
big stockpile allows you to be patient
the the more money you have the longer
you out you can think because you don't
have to worry about tomorrow you know
that next month and the month after and
the month after taking care of because
even if you made no money you've got
enough that's how you can start thinking
longterm people are like think think
longterm think long term but like unless
if you have payroll and you've got or
you've got rent or you've got you've got
groceries to pay you can't think
long-term because you're in survival
mode and so I'm trying to get Survival
to be as low as humanly possible for you
so that you could get into Thrive mode
but it's all relative if you make 40
Grand a month and spend 40 Grand a month
you're going to be in the same survival
mode but if you make 40 Grand a month
and spend four you're going to have
you're going to have every month you
make 10 months worth of income and so in
two months you've got you've got 20
months saved up you're good and then you
can get super aggressive that other 36
and start really betting to to double
down all right so here's the very broke
five six things that you can do to
immediately spend way less one stop
eating out discount groceries only two
stop buying new clothes go to Goodwill
only three only attend free friend
events all right so think of what I just
said think about all the events that
friends will tell you to come to
weddings Bachelor parties uh birthdays
um just nights out because it's thirsty
Thursday whatever only attend free
friend events and if they don't support
your goals they're not your friends
think about that if I said hey I've got
this goal and I said hey there's this
human being and he wants to get you to
not have the goal would you describe
them as a friend or an
enemy think about it some of you some of
the people in your life that you call
friends are actually your
enemies you just don't know it now four
take the rest of the time that you have
to a apply to jobs that make more than
your current job B pick up side hustle
work C learn skills that you can trade
for a higher hourly rate than you
currently
do when I say trade I mean you make more
per hour than what your current current
skills pay you all right and then five
find the hardest worker in the room when
you enter that new job or that new place
and then double their level of input so
if they knock on 100 Doors you knock on
200 they make a 100 dials you make 200
dials right when I had Jacob my young
neighbor I gave him this exact advice
and he was expected to on his team do
$100 a day he did between 300 and 400
and so guess what he got better faster
and then once you follow all of those
steps this is what you need to do next
wait 36 months and this is what I mean
by patient with your outputs impatient
with your inputs and the crazy thing is
that you can change your life in one
decision I can get drunk Drive in a car
and change my life forever right I can
happen like that but it can happen just
like that the other way it's just that
the outcome's delayed that's the only
difference you can change your life
today In This Moment by making these
decisions and the and your Life Path
will have veered you will have changed
Direction your tree of of life will move
it's just that it takes time for that
new direction to bear fruit whereas you
can poison the fruit in a second you can
kill a tree real fast you just can't
grow one real fast but it doesn't mean
that if a seed's planted and you're
watering it it's not growing it just
takes a second to get above the surface
I think you can solve a lot of male
Problems by getting in shape and making
money you'll still have problems they'll
just be smaller and you'll have more
resources to handle them so let's talk
about the making money part first
fundamentally in order to make money you
have to provide value to some someone
either an employer or customers but
either way you have utility which you
exchange for money and so by making that
a goal then it means that you're going
to increase your own usefulness and so
somebody who is more useful all of a
sudden develops other ancillary skills
around that utility that they can use in
other parts of their lives if you're
good at sales guess what you can do when
you're talking to girls you can use the
same conversational skill set if you're
trying to negotiate uh a purchase for a
car or a house or whatever like those
skills generalize they transfer across
domains and so a lot of people think
it's like well when would I ever be a
salesperson or when would I ever be
outbound what like it doesn't matter
it's not about that thing the thing is
it's like real life skills actually do
generalize like this isn't elementary
school or or middle school when you're
learning calculus or algebra or whatever
and thinking like what am I going to use
this in real life one it is real life
right now
two these skills do get used across
domains of all of my friends who are s
Millionaires and billionaires to a
person they started in what I would
consider a high volume sales environment
so that's either door knocking cold
calling or some sort of in-person
business where they had many many many
conversations with strangers on a daily
basis and I think there's and I'm
talking not like a a month or six months
I'm talking like three five years where
no one knew their name they were just
some faceless representative that stood
there at the door saw people sold
memberships sold Insurance sold solar
sold whatever and the thing is is like
skill development happens through volume
and feedback loop so it's the number of
repetitions you have times the amount of
improvement between repetitions brute
forcing the amount of volume definitely
will help if you can give yourself
feedback I've seen people say hey I've
actually made a 100 pieces of content
now this is like 1% of people because
most people do nothing but of the 1% of
people who say okay I post it every day
for a year the thing is is they didn't
do the most important part which is you
don't just like make a video and post it
and just every day like hey make a video
post it make a video post it you have to
look at what you did and what you could
do better fundamentally that is the the
Cornerstone of feedback and so you look
at the top 10 videos you made over the
last month and you say okay how do I do
more of that and how do I do less of the
bottom 10% and you just pick one thing
that you did well there and you try and
do it in every video going forward and
that develops a checklist of things to
do so that you develop a skill and So
speaking from my own experience the
first sales conversation I ever had
first off I had zero sales training no
one was like hey this is the script this
is how you go over they're like hey
here's a new lady go sign her up and so
I was like okay and I didn't even know
this was a sale I didn't know the I
didn't know the term sales I just he
said go sign her up and I said okay and
so I walked over and and she was like
Hey you know I want to know more about
the gym and I said well do you want to
know and she was like well I mean like
how much is it and I was like oh it's uh
whatever 150 bucks a month and she was
like okay and I was like you want to
sign up and she said I left my credit
card at home
and I was like okay and she was like
I'll be back with the credit card and I
was like cool and so I walked out and uh
it was like 2 minutes right and I walked
out and the owner Sam was there with a
few of other other gym owners he had
brought a few gym owners in so it was
like three or four gym owners there and
uh he was like damn he was like that was
fast and I was like yeah he's like you
closed her and I was like yeah and and
he was like with a credit card and I was
like oh no she's she's going to go get
it and she'll be back and they just
looked at each other
and then looked back at me and then just
started laughing at me uncontrollably
like couldn't breathe at how dumb what I
had just said was and the thing is is I
had no experience and I and I tell that
story because so many people assume that
like I walked out of the womb closing
deals you know what I mean like hey
nurse what are you doing later you know
what I mean
like but it wasn't like that right like
I didn't know I I didn't I even know the
term and so you know over time I just
started developing like okay well what
do you do and I watched other people say
I was like okay they start with asking
them why someone's there ask them about
their goals ask them things that they've
done in the past that didn't work I like
okay that that that seems to work okay
and then when they asked them to buy
then if they don't want to say yes they
ask them more questions rather than just
saying okay so I started to develop at
least an understanding of the framework
of how sales occurred but I still wasn't
good right and so then I went through
like that Rocky cut scene period where
this is where I'm very grateful for this
is that uh Facebook ads is when I
started running them in 2013 where super
cheap and so it actually gave me so many
repetitions because not only was I
taking 15 to 20 consults a day in person
I was also working leads and so I'm
talking to strangers over the phone to
set the appointments and so all I got
was just names on a list and I would
call them set the appointment like who's
this again you know all of that um and
then and by the way if you are local um
you just say the name pause with a
question mark at the beginning you're
like John and then they'll be like yeah
you're like this is Alex I'd pause and
they'd be like they're like who the [__]
is Alex I'd be like from Facebook you
signed up for our blah blah blah blah
blah our thing yeah I'm just calling to
make sure that uh you're not a crazy
person from the internet and neither am
I I was like we're actually on the
corner of X and Y I was like right next
to the 7-Eleven they're like yeah I'm
like okay cool well I just wanted to see
what time you want to come come by I was
like we have the sweetest facility in
the world not really but it's uh at
least pretty decent for this area but we
have five out of five coolness and they
would just laugh they be like I can make
it at six and I'm like six works I was
like do you want a picture of me or just
of the address and they're like just the
address I'm like all right sounds good
I'll text it to you and I'll see you
later today right so that kind like
notice the like half Giggles between
each word like it's it's showing that
you're positive tone person high energy
and someone's like man this guy seems
cool or this gal seems cool right and so
they're more likely to show up they're
more likely now if I maintain that tone
if they give me an objection I can pivot
really easily if I'm like neutral or
like hi I saw that you signed up on the
internet for our thing uh would you like
to come in they're like uh well tell me
more about it like well it's just you
have no you have no room for messing up
and so I always tried to have more
Rapport and bring a lot of energy and
the thing is is like if you've seen any
of my content I'm not naturally like a
high energy person um I will continue to
work which is different than being like
up here and so I developed a lot of
things to try and keep myself energized
and so I had a small trampoline that I
would bounce on uh before and between
every sales appointment it sounds
ridiculous but if you I'm telling it's
it's like a hundred bucks if you buy one
of those little trampolines and you
bounce either between sales calls or
between people like I'd have people
coming in as I was still bouncing and
I'd be like I know this is ridiculous I
was like but try and be in a bad mood on
a trampoline you can't do it you can't
do it you can't do it and I challenge
you too you could be in a bad mood if
you try jumping around like you feel
like such a child it's ridiculous but
what would happen is like I would really
I would would also get a little bit
exercise my blood would keep moving but
it's also just like mentally um
literally
bouncing gave me a lot of energy for
these appointments and so I say this
because I developed all of these things
over time and so if you're starting out
you're not going to be good that's why
you're new you have no experience but
there's a difference between there's a
story that um shoot I can't remember
where it is but there was a foreign kid
who had never seen a banana before and
so the adult gave the kid a banana and
so the banana so the kid took the banana
and then bit right into it with the skin
and
everything and another child was like
you're such an idiot and then the adult
yelled at that child and said no he just
doesn't know any better and there's a
very big difference between being dumb
and being inexperienced right now you
just don't have reps and so you're going
to make a lot of mistakes like biting
into the banana like at for just walking
letting someone walk away assuming it's
a Clos when they say that they're just
gonna come back and call you with their
credit card right by the way that never
happens um very rarely but instead uh
you want to just peel that banana you
want to bite into the banana bite into
the orange all of those mistakes as
quickly as possible and not judge
yourself for making the mistake and see
the mistake as part of the process of
being like that didn't work that didn't
work and if I develop enough of these
doesn't works then you just kind of walk
the the mindfield and you get to where
you're trying to go and people are like
wow you're so good at this and you're
like oh no no I actually just know all
the things not to say in a sale and then
they end up buying I just avoid all that
and then they buy and to be clear I
think I have a similar piece of advice
but for very different reasons of
telling young men in general or men to
work harder and it's not because I think
it's some sort of you know beating your
chest I'm an alpha whatever thing it's
just that for me the point of my life is
to become the best version of me and in
order to do that I need to learn because
there's huge subcrib between where I am
and where I want to go and the
discrepancy is going to get filled with
skills which means that I need to do
repetitions to acquire failures that I
can learn from to get better from and if
I can do more of that in a shorter
period of time I will learn more skills
and by definition I will shrink the
distance between myself and my ideal
self and so that is pretty much the only
thought process I have around this and I
also believe that you need to be patient
with outputs and impatient with inputs
so let me unpack that patience in
general is figuring out what to do in
the meantime so when someone says Hey be
patient what they just mean is figure
out something else to do in the meantime
and so if I'm telling you to be patient
with outputs it means that you basically
just have to figure out something else
to do in the meantime while you wait for
outputs to occur because you can't
output you can't money doesn't appear
you have to do something and then money
happens right but the doing something
part is the thing that you can control
the money happening is the part that you
don't control that comes afterwards it's
an outcome right and so when I say
patient with outputs that's the first
part the second part is impatient with
inputs and so if being patient is
figuring out what to do in the meantime
impatience is doing the thing in the
meantime right and so it's the opposite
of that it's the thing you do in the
meantime and so if you want to be
impatient with the input the input is
the thing that's the action you do and
so so by delineating that if you hear
yourself thinking man why hasn't this
happened yet you're talking about
outputs and that means great if I think
that thought I need to do more of this
input right and so use your input your
action your doing this the thing you use
your hands for as your coping mechanism
for your impatience without outputs I
want to say that one more time whenever
you have that feeling that things should
be happening faster use action as your
coping mechanism I used to write this
down a lot uh and say it which was
action alleviates anxiety and so when I
would have this anxiety about the future
of like why haven't I made it yet why
are these other people doing better than
me like is is this not going to work
what if I'm on the wrong path action
alleviates anxiety the only thing I can
control with that I was is that I would
work is that I would get better and the
key point there was that it wasn't just
working for work's sake it was working
with the intention to improve
and so you want to do repetitions
because by doing things more times you
get better at them typically just by
accident but if you were deliberate
about the point of doing this when I
started working at a gym going from a
white collar job it wasn't because I
wanted to become a trainer for the rest
of my life it was because I wanted to
learn the
skills and then I knew that once I
learned those skills if I owned a gym
then I would know how to do the training
part as well and that would be good for
me and so then when I was a gym owner
and when I started and started working
at a gym I wanted to own a big chain of
gyms that was my that was my whole goal
to start with I wasn't getting into this
for one like I never had the goal of
only owning just one gym and so even
when I started that gym the whole point
and I worked all the time because I
thought of all the things that I didn't
know how to do yet and so it wasn't
about great I've made it I own a gym it
was like I'm so deprived of where I want
to be I have I have to fill this Gap as
fast as I possibly can and so that's why
I spent so much time on this and got
feedback from as many human beings as I
possibly could who were ahead of me so I
want to say this clearly once I start up
my gym one I paid for a mastermind for
gym owners before owning a gym and I did
that because I figured well why would I
start a gym until I learn all the stuff
that you guys did wrong I was like I'll
just learn from all y'all's mistakes it
sounds like a great deal for me it
almost felt unfair I was like yeah okay
he said don't start at one of those
locations he said have good storefront
he said make sure that you have you know
good parking I was oo these are all good
you know good things she like don't go
too big I was like okay that's good and
they're like make sure your rent's under
this per foot I was like all right make
sure I got that right and so I took all
these notes in that I would have just
Mis made huge mistakes on the on the
upfront now once I did start my gym what
a lot of people don't know is that every
weekend I would either be on phone calls
or I'd be driving out to other gym
owners and I would and thankfully
because I was so young when I started my
business they were just like they felt
bad for me and so they would just sit
there and I'd be like hey why do you do
that hey why do you do that hey why do
you do that and it was like you know
they'd be like God you're such a pain in
the ass but I just wanted to learn right
but I was always like willing to help
them with anything they had you know
what I mean I was like let me show you
the stuff that's working well for me and
I would always just share it um and the
thing is is I would go there and they
would say they did something and I'd be
like huh that's weird that's different
than the other guy and I I like that way
better it didn't mean I had to take
everything as as fact but I got a lot of
ideas from that and then I would use
them and if they didn't work I would
just toss them out and if they did I
kept it and that's how I quickly
iterated the gym model to become much
better than a lot of people's models
despite me being younger because I was
able to leverage everyone else's
experience as fast as I could and jam it
into my own and so I think like the
people who move faster than life learn
faster and the only way you learn is by
changing your behavior with the same
conditions which means that if a person
walks in I say this is my six-point
script a person who's identical walks in
right afterwards if I've learned
something that script changes means same
condition new behavior and so if you
keep doing the exact same thing every
single day then you may not be learning
and it's a key point it's good to work
hard but it's good to work hard and
smart which means that the work you do
gets better because you tweak things and
so if you're not documenting the process
that you have and I'm not saying you
making content about it but literally
looking back at game footage looking at
the calls you did looking at the content
you did I do this today people ask me
like what are the masterminds you're
into what are the courses you learn from
I have now broken apart the learning
process that I have that works best for
me because I see the biggest gains in
Improvement haven't come from advice for
me for the most part they came from
looking at data which was let me look at
the last 2,000 ads I made let me look at
the top 50 let me look at what these
ones have in common let me look at what
they don't look like compared to the
bottom 50 okay these ones have these
characteristics these don't I'll do more
of this and less of that and then I do
another 100 ads and I look at the top 10
again I say what do these ones have that
these ones don't and I do that for sales
calls I do that for Content I do that
for meetings I do that for for
businesses in general when you start
zooming out and so that process of do a
lot of volume then look at the outcomes
that were good look at the activities
that led to those outcomes that are
positive do more of those activities
look at the bottom percentages look at
the things that led to not having that
happen and do less of those and if
you're younger and this is specific for
everyone who's listening to this video
if you're probably sub30 sub 28 maybe
right if you're in your 20s or less you
can probably get away with this which is
that people ahead of you are more
willing believe it or not to feel like
they have status so you can give them
status by saying be a mentor and the
thing is a lot of young guys have a lot
of ego right because you're trying to
prove yourself trying to be a man
whatever the thing is is that if you
humble yourself it's not like there's
some [__] massive scoreboard where
it's like who humbled themselves to whom
across the whole us it doesn't it's not
not exists it's just just within one
Dynamic right and so if you go and say
hey I don't know anything I'm happy to
learn if you do that then a lot of
people are like oh well he humbled
himself well yeah I'm happy to teach you
and the thing is they'll give you advice
that's worth thousands of dollars years
of your life for free if you just say
you're better than I am at this but the
thing is is that the end of the day none
of it matters but scoreboard would be
the thing that matters in business right
and so the only thing that precedes the
scoreboard is your learning I've spent
ego points I've spent dollars I've spent
time I've spent Social Capital I spent
every resource that I had to get more
learning faster because fundamentally
the only thing and I think this is
probably one of the biggest gifts my
father gave me is believing that I am
the asset I am investing in and the cool
thing is is that you are the permanent
hold right you can't sell you like
you're you until you die and so this is
the one asset you've got because you
compound skills compound when you get
really good at sales and really good at
Finance guess what you can raise a
billion dollars because you know how the
finance World works and you know how the
sales World works right if you know how
to if you know how to code and market
then guess what you can build software
and sell it to gazillions of people
because you have the product and the AC
acquisition like skills stack
disproportionately if you only know one
you might not be able to make a tenth as
much as if you know two now obviously
those are big bucketed terms that have
many many many skills underneath of them
but fundamentally when you think about
it that way you become a weapon so let's
tackle the second part I said you you
can solve a lot of male Problems by
getting in shape and making money and so
let's talk about the getting in shape
side so you can avoid tons of problems
in life by doing one thing going to bed
on time and so instead of setting alarms
to wake up set alarms to go to sleep on
time it's hard to wake up late when you
go to bed at 9: right and so the thing
is is that that one simple Behavior
actually can eliminate a lot of the
things that derail men especially young
men and so Charlie Monger talks about a
lot which is like all I'd want to do is
find out where I'm going to die and
never go there the whole point is he
thought so much more about avoiding
stupidity than trying to be intelligent
it's kind of like the stupidities are
very easy to identify the intelligence
is hard but if you avoid all stupidity
you just become intelligent by default
and so if you define intelligence the
way I do which is rate of learning so
how quickly you pick things up that is
intelligence if you can avoid all of
these things that make you look like an
idiot right then you become more
intelligent and so let's let's talk
about this from the from the the getting
in shape perspective show me a situation
where you have two groups of men one
group of men that is really out of shape
and fat and another group of men that's
really in shape that are going to
outperform one another and this is
generalized you have to take random
sampling of the population bunch of in
shaped guys a bunch of overweight guys
who's going to do better at any task
over and over again if we pick 10 tasks
that are completely different the in
shaped guys are going to do better than
the out of shape guys period they're
going to have more energy they're going
to be more focused if it's anything
inter related like inter relations based
like those guys are going to close
higher percentages if you're better
looking you will close more if you're
better looking you get paid more if
you're better looking you get more
promoted if you're better looking you do
better in content period fight me and so
the thing is is like if you have this
one thing that affects every way that
people see you and the only thing you
have to do is control what you put into
your mouth then don't you think it's
worth developing that most basic skill
of discipline at this point in your life
because the thing is is that you want to
get in shape young because if you're not
in shape guess whose fault that
is so get in shape now thing is is it
costs time not money and right now
you've got time and not money and time
only becomes more expensive as you age
so buy it now while time cost you the
least and you have have the fewest
responsibilities it'll help you no
matter what life path you choose the
thing that no one recognizes is that
drinking cost you two days the day you
drink and the day you recover and
sometimes the weeks afterwards for the
stupid thing you did while you were
drunk that everyone else saw it reminds
me of this quote from Muhammad Ali and I
asked my team to pull it up because I
think it's so good also because he was
the greatest of all time and just a cool
dude what's the the central part of your
training is it running is it sparring or
central part is dodging the nightclubs
and the parties and the
girls you want the truth and being in
the bed by yourself 9:00 at
night and if you can get by that you'll
make
it that's the truth now I tell you the
truth you talk all that running and
hitting the bags and jogging and vitamin
you want dodging ladies is the main
thing especially when you're pretty like
me and I'll speak to myself personally
when I had my intense periods of work I
would take off for a long long time so
the longest then I took off was two
years while I was scaling gym launch
from you know the 20 months we went from
zero to 4 and a half million a month 4.4
to be technical I didn't drink that
whole period And once things settled out
I was like all right I'm willing to
drink again and right now acquisition.
comom is scaling like crazy and so Lea
and I both said let's just stop drinking
for the foreseeable and same thing now
so that was when I was in my 20s this is
now when I'm in my 30s and I'll probably
continue this until I feel like I'm at a
place where things feel chill again and
then like maybe I'll I'll partake again
but the thing is is like if you're
hungry argue me the opposite which is me
drinking more will make it more likely
for me to hit my goals I think you'd
have a tough time making that argument
and so right now everything's
compounding is Amplified right the stuff
you do now amplifies throughout your
career and your life and so I would want
to Stack as many advantages as I can to
my favorite which is like I'm going to
go to sleep on time I'm going to not
drink right I'm going to get in shape
right I'm going to do as many
repetitions as I can I'm going to humble
myself with people who are more
experienced than I am even if I think
I'm smarter than them they still know
more and there's a big difference and
this is what I think is really tough for
younger guys is that your brain at 25 to
you know like 25ish 25 to 30 is like
Peak processing power but I'm way
[__] smarter now than I was then
because I've still learned more and
that's the thing is is that you may be
smarter than someone in sheer processing
power but they still might know more
than you and so you can't live their
life and especially if somebody is
further ahead then they it still means
that they have knowledge that you don't
and so listen and humbling yourself to
somebody even if you think you are
smarter will teach you more because
again argue the opposite I will learn
nothing from no one how does that help
you it helps you your ego feel good
but at some point your ego is going to
have to rectify its Good Feeling with
reality which is that you're broke as
[__] and no one cares and so I would
rather humble myself rather than have
the world humble me this is a Bible
quote that I just really like a lot it's
Matthew 23:12 he said those who are
humble will be exalted and whoever
exalts himself will be humbled I
actually told that to one of our our
team the other day because I felt like
his ego was getting a little bit bigger
than it probably should have been and I
said listen man I was like if you want
to get humbled keep doing what you're
doing I was like but if you want people
to talk you up I was like humble
yourself let your work work for you and
then everyone else will exalt you and so
I think most men want to be respected
they don't have respect and so they
compensate by exalting themselves
because it makes them feel better in the
short term but you look like an idiot in
the long term and think about it like
this like for some reason I don't know
why we're wired this way but we say nice
things about ourselves and we feel good
but everyone else feels bad right if
everyone else says nice things about you
it doesn't make them feel bad to say it
but it makes you feel good think about
those people in your life who always
like talk themselves up it's like what
do you see you're like this guy's so
insecure it's obvious and you look that
way you don't feel that way but you look
that way and some of the things that you
develop as you get older is the
separation between how I look and how I
feel which is like oh even though this
feels good I look dumb doing this your
feelings can lie to you in terms of how
well this behavior is serving you with
your goals in the long term and while
we're talking about your friends
exalting you and your friends saying
you're cool how much do their opinions
of you really matter because now this is
going to take a completely different
direction than you expected which is you
being humble is a description that other
people would give to you but it relies
on you caring a lot of what they think
which is a double-edged SW and the
younger you are actually at all points
it hurts you it's kind of like the stock
market one person two person one day or
two days in the stock market it's just
about sentiment but how big the stock
goes over a decade is about how good the
intrinsic stock is and so if a few
people say you're an [__] no big deal
if everyone says you're an [__]
probably a problem right and so it's
understanding the Nuance between that
but your friend group has a
disproportionate sway over your behavior
and so your reference group is one of
the number one correlations with how big
your life gets or rather the goals you
achieve now they've done the studies in
terms of Finance because it's easy to
quantify but your reference you're have
the five people you compare yourself to
not necessarily spend the most time with
but compare yourself to are the ones
that determine your future and so
sometimes you have to like your goals
more than you like your friends and
every person who wants to do something
in their life or has done something with
their lives is going through the exact
same chapter that you're going through
right now and it's the lonely chapter
it's the chapter where you don't fit in
with your old friends but you don't have
the achievements yet to fit in with a
new group of friends and you're doing
all the stuff right the fruit tutorials
you're watching these videos and you're
reading everything you can get your
hands on and you're trying to set up
whatever your podcast is or your content
thing right and you're going through it
and you're thinking to yourself like is
this even worth it because you're not
seeing any signs of success but the sign
of success is the hate that you get
along the way it is the leading
indicator and what you can't do is bend
the knee to their hate and try and fit
back in and conform because it's
comfortable and it's warm it's like the
scene in The Matrix when Trinity opens
the door the very beginning in the first
Matrix when Neo is about to take the red
pill and he wants to get out of the car
and Trinity says you've been down that
road Neo you know that road and you know
exactly where it ends and I know that's
not where you want to be and then he
closes the door and he gets back in and
he goes they they go to go take the red
pill so right now this moment that
you're going through is Trinity opening
the door and saying you could go back
you could go party you could go to the
nightclubs you could say that this was
just a hobby you could downplay what
you're doing like I'm just trying out oh
yeah I'm not I'm not really that into it
it's just like just some thing I found
right but then as you're saying you feel
like a fake cuz you're lying to yourself
you're lying to them about what you re
what your real intentions are and in
that moment when you're trying to think
about having that conversation you
remember exactly why you left why it is
that road and you know exactly where it
ends and that's not where you want to be
and the thing is is that your goals will
stick with you longer than these
relationships your goals will serve you
more than these relationships and this
is what this is the stuff that no one
will tell you I can tell you personally
I don't talk to I talk to one friend
that I have from middle school and high
school all right I talk to one person
two people from college and it's not
like we talk all the time I talk to him
every six months or so and so I say this
because although these relationships
feel like they're incredibly important
in your life right now they will
disappear the majority of these of these
friendships are based on convenience
you're only friends with them because
they lived in your dorm they lived in
your neighborhood they went in to
English class with you but as soon as
your conditions change you change where
you're at all many of them will fade
away because you'll develop new skills
you'll develop new context you'll meet
new people who are upskilled from that
and then you'll compare them to compare
to these people and you'll be like man
these are better friends these are
people who are more aligned with my
goals they're trying to grow when I want
to work all day Saturday they're like
cool I'll work with you rather than
being like dude we're going on a pontoon
boat where you going to be and you have
to accept that as the price and the
thing is it's like it's only if you want
that like if you if you want to live a
life that is the same as everyone else's
then you can do what everyone else does
the only issue is when you want to do
what everyone else does but get what
none of them have if you want to be
exceptional by definition you will be
the exception you will not be normal you
will be unlike the others and so it
makes sense that you would be in the
outgroup and it hurts as a human being
because you want to be in the ingroup
it's part of our DNA shame is a real
thing and we don't want to feel that
because in in the real in the in the N
natural world if you're outside of the
group you have a much lower likelihood
of living and procreating so it's strong
in our DNA to be in group but the thing
is is that you're actually not in group
or out of group you're transitioning
you're between groups and so in that
lonely chapter that's where you can do a
disproportionate amount of work because
you have no distractions so you listen
to the podcast you read the tweets you
watch the videos you consume the content
because you know deep down I can do more
than this and you begin to see the
person that you could be and realize how
far you need to go to get there but
despite how far away it seems your goals
the best version of you you look back
down the Dead End Road and you know
that's not where you want to be and so
you keep going and realize that there's
no turning back once you see the
Promised Land once you see what you
could become you can't go back and if
you're not sure who your real friends
are one ask is it more likely or less
likely that I hit my goals with this
person in my life just think about it
like if this person is in my life is it
more likely my goals then remove them
because it's better to have friends who
force you to grow than ones who accept
you as you are because the biggest risk
to your future isn't your future
competition or your Rivals it's the
distraction that you insist on keeping
in your life rather than doing the
things you know you should be doing but
aren't think about it like this imagine
a competitor that you'd never want to go
against focused persistent always
learning always improving Relentless
says no to everything but that which
makes them stronger you know what he
looks like you know how he acts you know
who he Associates with great that's
future you now become him you have to
kill your current self for your new self
to have room to grow and so it's this
constant appraisal of your skills and
activities and saying which of these
makes me stronger which of these makes
it more likely for me to hit my goal and
I just want to give you that frame
because that like that single frame of
is this person being in my life make it
more likely or less likely that I hit my
goal is this activity or this behavior
that I do make it more or less likely I
hit my goal and I consistantly just ask
that question over and over and over
again and that is because for me I do
love my goals more than I love my friend
because my goals will be with me long
after they are and so if you think about
your relationship with your goals and
you put it on the same pedestal or
higher than your relationship with your
friends you're going to lose one of the
relationships and the question is which
one is the one that's going to serve you
more in the long term that's a decision
for you but for me I can tell you
personally achieving my goals has served
me more than any one person has and
because achieving your goals is a
generalized thing it can open all doors
to new relationships and so you do have
to burn sometimes what you have in order
to have what you want if you want to
impress poor people out spend them if
you want to impress rich people outwork
them and I can tell you this being in
the position that I'm at because I have
tons of young men who work for me and I
mean they hear all the content that I
make and they know that and so if you
lease a Ferrari for $5,000 a month or
whatever I know you're not rich and
every rich person isn't impressed by
that because we know what it costs you
only impress poor people and if you do
it really early in your career every
rich person's like man you should be
reinvesting that to get way Fu bigger
now if you're like in a ficado and you
want to have lots of cars and that's
like again that's different it depends
on the reason you're doing it it's like
you shouldn't be cooking your own food
unless you love cooking but if you don't
love cooking then you should Outsource
that [__] as fast as possible so that
you can get your time back it's
understanding the context of this which
of course this will be taken out of
context but hopefully you watching or
listening to this can at least get it
Lea and I both collectively started
buying nicer things so living in nicer
places having nicer cars I bought my
home which was a nice house in Austin I
think it cost me 1.7 million I bought it
in cash and I bought it off one month
paycheck and so I want to put that in
context to like was it a ball in house
totally it was sick I was super happy to
be there but where I lived before that
cost me 1,200 bucks a month and so
you're like wait one point set right we
spend money but by percentage the amount
of money we spend is inconsequential if
you want to buy the toys and you want to
buy that stuff I'd say sure understand
one whatever you spend you're taking
away from the future now there is always
a point you have to balance between
consumption and investment if you never
spend anything you live you live your
entire life and you end up with a big
pile of money and you didn't enjoy any
moment of that I don't think that's the
way to do it but I do think there's a
ratio there and I think that ratio
depends on you as an individual I tend
to always over index on investment
because I just I want to become a really
like great version of me and I think
that's going to cost money and it's
going to cost time and I like to be
ready for those opportunities because
the opportunities get bigger and have
more zeros next to them and there's no
masterminds you get to at a certain
level you just do a deal with someone
and for me to Pony up for the deal might
be like hey you got to write a check for
10 million I'm like all right I got to
have that ready for just like on the
sidelines waiting for opportunities
right and so the idea is being on the
defensive so that you can be on the
offensive it's living far below your
lifestyle so that you can more heavily
invest in the growth of the business and
so your lifestyle is your competitor's
opportunity there's you and other
version of you there's Bizarro you right
and Bizarro you wants to live this great
lifestyle and has the Ferrari and the
nicer place and whatever but when an
opportunity comes along Bizarro doesn't
have any savings because he's trying to
to show face right but the thing is is
that every's trying to show face for
hates him anyways because it looks like
he's bragging but also they know how
much he makes relatively and they're
like God he's got to be spending his
whole check paycheck he looks
irresponsible there's zero advantage to
being accurately judged if you are
strong you want to appear weak you want
to have more money than people expect
you to have and so for me when we did
buy the Bentley which I bought because I
got I'll be honest I got pressured into
it they're like dude come on you make
all this money like buy something nice
for yourself and I was like I guess
people buy nice cars so I bought a car I
bought a Bentley and um I returned it
six months later uh and I lost 20 grand
on it and I was like this was just a
complete waste of everything like I just
don't care at all about this because you
only need three things to win you can
write this down the balls to start the
brains to learn and the heart to never
quit and the good news is you already
have all three you're just not using
them because fundamentally if you found
somebody and they started and they
contined to get better and they never
stopped they would win just think about
it from fundamental Basics like if I
said okay think of a person who only did
one thing and all they dedicated their
entire life to is doing that one thing
and getting better and better at that
thing and they did it for 50 years do
you think that person would not be
incredibly successful of course they
would be then why aren't you doing it
the problem is it's never been easier to
start a business it's also never been
easier to do nothing at all and this is
what I mean by your distractions are the
things that are getting in your way
preventing you from doing the things you
already know you should be doing but
aren't right now if I were to say hey go
get in shape what do you need to do what
you want to say is I'm going to go do
some research to find the best program
and to find the best diet but if I just
said no no no you can't look make a
guess what would you say probably like
well I need probably like go to the gym
probably do some weights probably do
some cardio move a little bit or to say
do you want to stay at the same weight
do you want to stay at the same cardio
Pace or do you want to move those up
over time you probably say I want to
move those up over time like okay and
then foodwise like do you want to
probably eat more protein and Eli [__]
probably like yeah like well why don't
we just start there most of the things
you need to do you already know what to
do and you delay doing them by under the
guise of having a better plan but the
reality is that your plan is always
going to change as soon as you get new
information and so the point is to start
period and learn and it's giving
yourself permission to have the humility
to start a role that you know is not
going to be your endgame because you
just see it as one tile on the painting
that's going to become the version of
you that you want it's like I got to
start at this corner I'm going to paint
this corner up because I know that this
Cornerstone of experience in door Todo
or cold calling or media buying whatever
is going to be something that I can
build my whole career off of there are
maybe trillions of dollars but at least
hundreds of billions of dollars that are
being made and dedicated every day to
getting you to do nothing it's not a
fair fight I want to be clear it's not a
fair fight and they're winning and so I
love this from from Andy forel he said
personal Excellence is the ultimate
rebellion and so I think like you want
to be a [__] Rebel be excellent and
do it for you like you want to stick it
to the man now just be great
fundamentally the point of entertainment
is to get someone to pay attention to it
that's all entertainment does is pay
attention to me right and so that means
that you're not paying attention to the
thing that matters more to you in the
long term and so every dollar every
minute of attention you pay to
entertainment whether that's poring
alcohol going out the clubs uh all of
social media in general motivation porn
if you will all of that is you not doing
what you need to do to get to where you
want to go you just have to be able to
do things without seeing an immediate
reward like if there's one meta skill
that that overshadows all of this it's
your ability to delay gratification is
to delay a moment of reward that's it
like that's all you have to do and in
the beginning you just have to be able
to do it long enough that you get one
reward and that reward is typically
outsized in its strength and then that
will reinforce you sticking with it
because the people who do work really
really hard it's not like they're made
of different Flesh and Blood than you it
just means that they had a short period
at some point where they said I'm going
to shut everything else off and I'm
going to go all in on this and then when
they do get that first feedback loop
like holy [__] I made my first sale holy
[__] I I got my first lead from from ads
holy [__] I got my first you know 100
followers whatever it doesn't matter
like you have some feedback loop for
whatever it is that you're trying to go
after that then encourages you to do
more and you're like oh this could work
and then as soon as that turns on you
can get obsessed with it if I had to
sign a contract right now to be that you
guaranteed that you'd be a millionaire
in 10 years but you couldn't make any
real money between now and then would
you sign it every person I've asked says
yes and so maybe if you are listening to
this and you're not your head like okay
I'm 30 I'm a millionaire yeah that
sounds like a great deal by the way
that's like 0. whatever 1% like no one
is but if that's you a lot of stuff
takes much longer and the problem is
that when you're 20 you've only been an
adult for like 3 seconds and so the
thing is that 3 seconds feels a very
long time but I have this belief that
older people are more patient not
because they're actually more patient
it's just because your perception of
time speeds up I can be more patient
than a 5-year-old because for me one
year is not 20% of my life so my
perception of time shrinks I might have
the same patience as a 5-year-old it's
just that more time passes and so if you
are younger then you have to just
understand that your perception of time
will speed up and so you will be able to
exhibit patience you'll keep being able
to do something in the meantime because
the meantime will pass faster and so you
have to over index on it when you're
starting I mean I've got guys on my team
who are like hey what's my next career
move and they're like 30 days into their
job and I'm
like give it a second like you still
suck like you went from suck to
proficient like you're not great yet
calm down the real world's very
different from school which you've
already if you're watching my stuff you
already kind of have an idea about that
but I want to give you the more the
behavioral definition around it is that
with school you have very clear
directions and a clear outcome with a
clear timeline and you get a grade
immediately so that's kind of like the
roar or feedback loop right and
sometimes it's Pop Quiz same day next
day you get the the feedback loop or
even you get you finish the quiz you go
outside and you're like hey would you
answer for six you're like a [__] I got
it wrong or whatever right but the thing
is that the world is completely opposite
of that and so the re the thing is is
that beginners are paralyzed to make a
decision because they assume the real
world works like school and only has one
right answer but reality is is that
there are many right answers with only
one wrong answer which is doing nothing
and that's the answer that most people
pick so I was talking to Neil Patel
who's a friend of mine and he just made
this uh this big tweet about this but he
and I had a conversation about it
earlier he has two friends one who's a
public uh CEO found a company took it
public he's got another friend who found
a company took a public took it back
private and then now only does Private
deals the guy who does public and made
all his money public is like you got to
go public and the other guy who took his
company public and it was a big mess and
then took your private again is actually
richer than the guy who made his company
public both those guys are billionaires
and both gave advice and they had differ
advice and so I don't see it as one is
right or wrong it's that there are many
right paths but only one thing will
prevent you from achieving all of it
which is the only thing I'm trying to
comper in this video is getting you to
not do the one wrong path which is fear
fear of not making it work fear of of
other people's disapproval who don't
matter anyways that you aren't cool
anymore or because you don't show up to
social events or because you don't blow
money on stuff that doesn't matter
anymore or you're not wearing the brands
that they think are cool is all of that
worth you for the rest of your life
having the crushing feeling of
mediocrity knowing you could do more and
I say and I can describe this because
I've lived it it's why I say it I'm not
saying that that stuff's not going to
happen it absolutely will happen it
might even be worse than you imagine but
you will not die and if you use the
frame does me losing all of these
relationships and having more time
increase the likelihood that I get to my
goal or decrease the likelihood they get
to my
goal all of a sudden when you use the
goal frame of the best version of you
all of a sudden it starts to it starts
to make things a lot clearer it's like
no me going to this bachelor art party
does not increase the likelihood that to
hit my
goals and I'm not saying that you have
to to make that sacrifice every time but
the thing is is you're making a
sacrifice either way you're either
sacrificing your goals or you're
sacrificing that relationship and so
some of you guys are like oh Alex that's
sounds unbalanced I'm going to get a
couple you know comments from the
[__] online therapists of like I
think emotional well-being and mental
holness is super important well first
off the pendulum swimming back no one
gives a [__] about the soft stuff
anymore thank [__] God but at some
point everyone who wants to achieve
great things realizes that balance is a
myth and once they realize that they
become someone who achieves great things
at some point every person who wants to
achieve great things realizes that
balance is a myth
and once they realize that they become
someone who achieves great things and so
there's this whole misnomer this whole
idea think about what mediocrity is it's
about being in the middle it's the
medium it's being right in the middle
right
balance but anybody who is imbalanced is
another way of saying more focused on
the one thing will be better at that
thing than you and the question is just
whether or not that thing that they
choose to be better at will give them
more leverage over all that other stuff
later
and so if you work very hard and you
create something that's very valuable
for society I promise you you will be
able to find a hotter wife I promise you
you will have the money that you want I
promise you you can buy the time that
you want to have you'll have all of that
at your disposal but if you choose the
balanced life there's nothing wrong with
that I just see that there is balance
over a lifetime rather than Balan at
every moment of life and so you might
have seasons like I took basically a
year off during the last year gym launch
I just didn't really do a lot so I had
more time than anybody and money right
but I had Seasons before that where I
didn't take any time off and so I think
if you expand your time rizon for what
balance really means that this is a
softer way of explaining it uh then I
think that that will you know make you
sleep well at night but real talk I work
all the time because I like to do it and
I think that once you get a fast
feedback loop with the work that you
like that also propels your goals then
you're not going to to do anything else
and that's it's not not like I or some
of the people that all right it's not
like the people that you look up to have
some sort of Herculean work ethic or
discipline that you don't they like
things that happen to also bring them
status and that means that they went
through a small period where they
started doing that thing when they
weren't good at it and it didn't bring
them status but they were able to make
it through that bridge until eventually
did start working and did bring them
status and then they just kept going so
you just need enough Gusto to start and
just get through that period to just get
through your friends saying you suck for
a little bit and everything you start
will not be fun cuz you'll suck but
getting good is fun getting better is
fun and so I get excited a lot of times
when I see how bad I am at something
that's new because I have enough
generalized reinforcement for learning
how to get better at things that you
learn the skill of getting better like
that's a meta skill you learn how to
learn and so just see it as an
opportunity to learn how to do anything
better so if you have a first thing then
that's the first thing that you get
better at and then you'll learn the
skill of getting better and you can
apply it all over the place some of you
guys are listening to this and you're
like okay you know this is great I'm
feeling awesome the thing is is that
people maybe it's you are waiting for
this perfect moment but it doesn't come
right it happens the moment you decide
that you're fed up with waiting and
decide to take action and it only
becomes the perfect moment when you look
back on it because today it just looks
like now I had a conversation with a
young man yesterday who said listen I
have
demons and I was like bro you don't have
[__] demons I was like shut up and he
was like I like the thing is this and I
I was so visceral with my reaction
because I used to say that kind of stuff
because I thought it made me hard I
thought it made me complex I thought it
made me mysterious but it's you don't
have demons you're not self-sabotaging
you don't have mom or dad issues what
you have is a lack of skills in how to
behave in a certain condition So when
you say you have demons what it really
means if I say okay what do you mean by
that Define them that how do what is
Define having demons right what I don't
most people say that they don't mean
they actually think they have spiritual
Demons Inside of them I'm not even going
to touch that what they really mean is
that under these conditions I behave a
way that is not ideal and so what that
means is you have a skill efficiency no
[__] you're inexperienced of course you
have a skilled deficiency you don't have
demons you don't know how to be
consistent you're not you don't have I I
just can't stay with anybody for a long
time no it either means you have really
high standards which is fine and youd
haven't met that person yet or you just
don't know how to behave
consistently it's like when I have a
sales guy who's like hey you know I'm 30
days into this world and I'm getting I'm
getting kind of board taking sales calls
I'm like oh your ability to not be able
to continue after something gets boring
and learn to love the incremental
improvements the hundred or thousand
repetitions is the skill discrepancy
that you need to overcome the best sales
people bad sales people try and have a
couple good days good salese get on hot
streaks great salese never get cold and
so that takes discipline to understand
how to consistently get yourself hot how
to consistently treat every sale the
same way you do when you're on fire
because there is no being on fire it
means you simply behave differently it's
not like you have magic you you pause
differently you take longer spaces you
ask the question your tonality shifts
and those are skills because you can
learn them and so this whole thing of
like this is this young man I'm
traumatized first off you don't even a
[__] definition of trauma all right
trauma is a permanent change in behavior
from an aversive stimulus meaning
something bad happens and forever it
changes how you act now let's if we
understand that as the definition of
trauma is trauma bad well if I touch a
stove and then I never touch a stove
again when it's hot is that trauma bad
it permanently changed my behavior from
an aversive stimulus is that trauma bad
well it prevented me from getting
burning the house down from you know
permanently damaging my hand in the
future no I would say it was good and so
this whole appraisal of your past being
tough or you don't understand bro no and
no one cares either they don't
understand nor do they care and so all
anyone is going to care about is how you
act how you behave what you do based on
a series of conditions and so you just
need to expose yourself to the
conditions so that you can get the
repetition so that you can learn how to
overcome it the thing that determines
whether it's good or bad is whether it
creates a behavior that's condusive to
your goals and so that means that
fundamentally you can have a stimulus
like touching the stove that creates a
behavior that is conducive to the goal
in that way trauma was good so by the
way parents when you punish a child the
hope is that you traumatize them is that
you permanently change their behavior
from an aversive stimulus it's just that
people don't Define words and they just
shout them all over the place say say
it's stored in your body it's energy
it's like no one even knows what the
[__] that means means show me on
someone's body where it's stored give me
an x-ray show me where the no come on
like you're saying you're you you're
storing your emotional Trauma from your
father and your
liver like I can just say words and make
things up and get people notd if I say
them with conviction it doesn't make
it's true and so you may have been
fooled because sometimes it's more
convenient to say you can cast your
power onto this thing that happened that
was outside of your control as the
reason why you can't be successful
because it's easier to say that than to
say that I chose not to do anything
about it
anyways and again listen you can do
whatever you want you can just keep
wallowing in that you can keep saying
that that's the reason and wherever you
point is where your power is right but
the only time that you have more power
is if you say it's on you period because
all of those things may have happened
and they may have all been
terrible and what are you going to do
about it right because the only like no
one cares like the world doesn't care
you care which is fine but like no one
else does and the sooner you realize
that the sooner you can start doing
something about it and so also think
about this it's the equal opposite if
trauma can create good things then it
also means that good things can create
bad behaviors and so if you win the
lottery and then you have all these
behaviors that happen afterwards that
are negative then was it good for you
like we talk about these rich and
privileged kids because it creates
behaviors that people that actually make
it less likely they achieve things like
later and so just think about what
occurred and what behaviors you take as
a result and separate good or bad from
it and just think does it make it more
likely that I hit my
goals it makes life a lot easier and
then it stops you from speaking in
Voodoo and speaking and appealing to
mysticism and Magic like there's this
this Force around of demons it's like
dude no like you had a girl who cheated
on you okay now what does that change
about your behavior I have trust issues
no it just means that under these
conditions you are slower to give
someone access to your bank account or
slower to move in with someone comma who
cares and is that a bad thing and so
I'll walk you through a three-step
framework that has been unbelievably
valuable to me and this is from Dr cashy
logic evidence
utility logic is what does that mean so
you have demons okay what does that mean
Define it in terms of behavior what does
that mean okay got it now how do you
know that evidence so you say I have
demons we unpack that and it means that
uh for you you self-sabotage which again
Define that okay it means that I show up
late to meetings after I get into a job
after two months of being on time okay
so after 2 months of be on time you
start being late to stuff that we
translated from I have demons to I
self-sabotage to that is the behavior
that occurs got it now I would say how
do you know that now a lot of times
people like well it's happened but when
you actually look at it you're like it
happened three times over in you know in
my my last job okay is it really a a
problem as you define it or it happened
in those three occurrences okay got it
so now you know now most times people
like I don't have any data and you're
like okay so then this is basically made
up and when I say made up I'm not saying
it's like you are a High I'm just saying
that humans work in narratives and a lot
of times we add narratives stories to
things that don't actually mean
anything but it's convenient and it's
fun and we like talking about it but it
doesn't mean it's true and so then you
move to the third one which is and so
what utility who cares why does this
matter and so then you say okay well
this matters because it decreases the
likel that I will be able to retain
future employment fine then what do we
do about it and so you can walk through
things that you have struggled with in
the past with simply saying let me
Define this in terms of behavior how
what evidence do I have that this is
actually true and that I've defined it
based on these things and who
cares I have demons in the kitchen all
right just as a completely ridiculous
example okay well in my past I I've had
bad things happen bro like what like
what occurred I touched the stove and it
burns me okay great now we have
something evidence-wise how many times
it happen one time okay and it never
happened again in the future okay what
did that result in I don't go into
kitchens anymore okay now this is good
or bad when you say who cares it's in
relation to what my goals does you not
going into the kitchen prevent you from
achieving your goals well if you want to
be a chef yes if you want to be an
entrepreneur no if you want to be a
kitchen entrepreneur probably right and
so the question is just who cares why
does it matter and so so much of our
time and effort goes into explaining
things things to people that don't
matter at all that you could literally
just move on from and just literally
forget about you could get over that
quote trauma by changing the behavior
that it changed aversively so in this
context or in this condition I behave
this way and it's not conducive to my
goals great that's good that you've
identified it cool so what do we need to
do so that when you're in the condition
how can we increase the likely that you
do act the way that you want to and then
you start stacking the deck to start
Shifting the pendulum in your favor and
you start attacking each of these little
problems from skill that you have
whether it's Behavior with people or
it's skills at work or with a
relationship and you just do it one by
one by one and if you do it over a very
long period of time you get better I
promise you and I'm saying this to
somebody who I struggled with my demons
you don't understand bro like I have
stuff like
okay but it doesn't help you and it also
doesn't make you look
harder it just makes you less
capable losers talk about what happened
to them winners talk about what they
made happen despite it hardship is a
reality for losers to Winners hardship
is just your origin story and like I
promise you if you can use this Frame
like I was texting LEL the other day
like the bigger the monster the more
epic the hero it's the story that you're
going to someday tell when you're 85
you're not going to want more boring
stories right the idea is that if you're
going through hard [__] now that's the
story that you're going to tell and if
you believe yourself to be the hero that
you want to someday become then the
harder it is you're like bring it this
is my my story this is the Spider-Man
getting bid this is him getting beat up
by the bullies this is the origin story
no one cares about a hero who never had
it hard I bought a lottery ticket years
and years and years ago when I was in
college because it was like a a billion
or something like that back back then
that was one a billion dollars meant
something
um but I was in college and the and my
girlfriend at the time I was talking to
her and the drawing was that night we
bought him for fun we bought one tick I
wasn't expecting to win but it was just
a it basically I was buying her for the
conversation and I thought about it as
like the drawing got closer and I
realized I had this big pain of anxiety
cuz I was like What if I win and I had
this moment of Terror because I realized
that if I won that I would never be able
to achieve anything that anyone thought
was my
own and that thought terrified me and
thankfully I didn't win the billion
dollars um and I got to make the life
that I have and so I think that I think
epic tetus says this but it's something
to the degree of what a shame it would
be for someone to never encounter
hardship because they would never be
able to see who they
are and so I think that if you have gone
through hardship or you are going
through hardship this is the opportunity
to prove to yourself not anyone else
that you are who you say you are and you
are made of what you say you are made of
and you can
choose to allow that hardship to make
you harder to make you more resilient to
make you more persistent to make you
more Relentless to make think you more
driven towards whatever you want to do
or whoever you want to be or you can
allow it to be an ankle weight you can
allow it to be your trauma right that is
your demon that you're fighting every
day but the thing is is like everyone
has demons everyone has hard [__] and I
want to tell you this frame that'll
hopefully change someone's perspective
which is that your hard stuff may have
been harder than other people's hard
stuff but if I take a human being who is
never encountered anything and then I
poke them with a needle that will be a
10 out of 10 hardship for them and so I
believe personally that humans
experience pain the same way it's why
when a man feels disrespected it hurts
just as much as someone else going
through another crazy hardship and you
know what even if that guy's white a 10
out of 10 Pain still feels like a 10 out
of 10 pain now could that pain be less
on the absolute scale of worst scenario
yeah it could be but also who
cares and so my point here is that every
single human being on Earth has gone
through their version of 10 out of 10
pain which normalizes pain across the
Spectrum which then leaves you with the
only natural thing you have left which
is what do I do now and if you wanted to
design the perfect version of You The
Savage competitor the Gladiator at the
end of the life that has the scars and
the scraggly beard but has been through
[__] and has done things and has and has
realized their potential What would you
do to maximize the likelihood that you
become that Savage hero would you give
them the padded lifestyle would you give
them the immediate win would you give
them the Easy Life probably not you
would probably put you through what
you're going through right now to become
that person and so why would you resent
the chapter you're in because it's a
requirement for becoming who you say you
want to be let's say you've gotten over
your little demon thing and when I say
gotten over you just stop giving it
Power by saying it now is the reason
that you can't be successful awesome so
what do you do now right so you got to
start figuring things out and that
figured out muscle is probably the most
powerful muscle you can build it's just
saying oh I don't know how to do this I
will figure it out why because I figured
out things in the past and I can do it
again and if that person can do it and
they're no smarter than I am they have
two hands in a brain I can do it too so
the next time that you say you can't
figure something out just set a timer
for 20 hours and actually try for 20
hours before you quit what you'll often
realize is it's not hard you just
haven't even tried yet if you you can
shrink the time between saying you want
to learn something and beginning to try
the thing and extend the time before you
say hey this is hard then you will be
able to accomplish way more than you
think you can learn most things in 20
hours the problem is that most people
delay the first 20 hours by years and if
you really measured Yourself by the
amount of action you take not your
desire not your deservingness or even
your effort you might actually be
embarrass because what you're looking at
is reality it's about what you do not
what you say you're going to do how much
you want the outcome from what you're
doing how much you think you deserve the
thing that's going to happen after you
do it or how hard you try because one no
one cares two reality doesn't care
either because the only thing that
matters that you can control is input
and you would be absolutely astonished
at what you can accomplish when you give
yourself no choice every third time I do
a Q&A I get asked the question what
keeps you going when things were tough
like what did you think about and I
could come up with something that was
really compelling but the honest truth
is I just never considered quitting it
was just not it was just not on my
choice of options at the table because
for me the idea of going back to
Baltimore as a failure was so much worse
than anything else that I could
encounter that it just it just wasn't
even a consideration and so the only
natural option I had was to persist was
to endure was to continue and so I think
if you use that frame as there have been
people who have gone through
significantly worse than what I'm going
through right now and for those of you
who claim the demon card of like I've
been through [__] then prove it was it
worse than this great then you can prove
that it was so hard by being hard now
across time frames in history across
countries across cultures across age
groups across race gender everyone
respects the man who works because as
men we are always judged by what we can
do and if you are doing things then
people know that you are contributing
that is how you prove utility work ethic
is the currency of respect
if you want to earn respect you earn it
through work and sometimes that's
working on yourself that's sometimes
working on a skill working on a product
but it is all through work through
effort I will tell you something that
shifted my life which is that
entrepreneurship is not a game of best
man wins it's a game of Last Man
Standing and there's a lot of games that
are like this and fundamentally that's
an infinite game frame versus a finite
game frame and I will read you the quote
that Lila had framed and put in my
office ask the girl shoot the shot
launch the business run the ad quit the
job take the risk because when you're 85
years old and on your deathbed you're
not going to wish you had fewer crazy
stories